ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد حاله ذعر شديده
عاشها مواطن تركيا وسوريا ودول عده جراء
الزلزال امس الذي اعاد الى اذهانهم
الزلزال الذي حصد ارواح عشرات الالاف حتى
باتت زلازل كانها هاجس مخيف لدى شعوب
المنطقه وربما في دول كثيره اخرى خاصه مع
احساس سكان دول عربيه وشرق اوسطيه بالهزاد
الارضيه الارتداديه مع وقوع زلزال انطاكيا
الاخير غادر معظمه سكان هاتاي وسط مخاوف
شديده من تكرار مشاهد السادس من فبراير
الحالي ونقلت مشاهد عن مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لسكان في تلك المناطق وهم في
الشوارع يرفضون العوده الى منازلهم رغم
بروده الطقس في شمال السوري حيث يوصف
الوضع هناك بالاسوء فقد رمى بعض السكان
بانفسهم في شققهم غير مفترسين بمادى
ارتفاعها ما ادى الى مقتل خمسه تورينا
واصابه العشرات بجروح وكسور نتيجه التدافع
والسقوط من ارتفاع عال
ارشادات الامم المتحده في حال وقوع
الزلازل ضروره توفر خطه طوارئ معلومه
لجميع افراد العائله
اذا حدث الزلزال والاشخاص داخل المنزل
الحفاظ على الهدوء وعدم الركض الابتعاد عن
الاشياء المحتمل سقوطها في الشارع
الابتعاد عن الاشجار واعمده الكهرباء
والمباني والاشياء التي يمكن ان تسقط
اثناء القياده الابتعاد عن الجسور ركن
السياره في منطقه امنه البقاء في السياره
حتى انتهاء الهزه الارضيه
الجانب النفسي مهم للغايه في هذا الاطار
ونحن سنسال عن هذه الجزئيه بالتحديد من
القاهره معنى الدكتور عمار علي حسن واستاذ
وعلم الاجتماع ومن سرمدا عضو مجلس اداره
الدفاع المدني السوري احمد يزجي اهلا بكم
ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي قبل البدء ان نقرا
بعض تعليقات المتابعين باننا فتحنا المجال
لاسئلتهم
وتعليقاتهم كذلك شيرين من العراق تقول هل
المناطق التي تقع على البحر الجغرافيا هي
اكثر عرضه للزلازل وكان اجابنا ضيفنا في
الجزء الاول وقال يعني ليس اكيد مع تاثير
حجم السدود الضخمه هل حبس انفس الارض التي
تقع في تلك المناطق تؤثر كذلك اجاب على
هذا الموضوع وقال بانه الطبقات في داخل
الارض هي التي تؤثر اكثر ولماذا ارصد
الزلزال لا يستطيع التنبؤ والتحذير قبل
وقوعها كما يحصل التنبؤ في الاجواء سواء
في الحر او البرد
وقال بانه هذا الموضوع يصعب التنبؤ به
هناك بعض التعليقات الاخرى حسام الدين
حافظ يقول يجب على المواطنين اخلاء منطقه
الهزات الارتداديه لتجنب حدوث الزلزال مره
اخرى الى اي مدى هناك قدره على ذلك سنسال
في هذا الموضوع
بعض الاسئله الاخرى تعليق اخر تساؤلات في
التنبؤ بالزلازل لماذا لم يتواصل العلماء
لتنبؤ بالزلازل طرحنا الموضوع مثلما الحال
في التنبؤ بالاحوال الجويه على كل الاسئله
عديده تصلنا ولكن في هذا الجزء اجبنا على
معظمها ولكن لطرح كل الاسئله اجرنا على
معظمها ولكن في هذا الجزء سنسال عن الجانب
الانساني خاصه واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع
القاهره من القاهره معك دكتور عمار دكتور
عمار لماذا
نشاهد حاله زعر
ما الذي يحدث بالتحديد
اجتماعيا ما الذي يحدث في طريقه ادراكنا
استيعابنا متابعتنا لهذه التفاصيل حتى يصل
باحد السكان وهناك مجموعه في الواقع
بالقاء نفسه عند احساسه باي هزه ارتداديه
من بعض الزلزال الاول مما اودى بحياه
البعض وجرح البعض الاخر
رغم ان كثيرا من الدول لديها مساحات شاسعه
وليس هناك داعي لهذا التوسع الراسي في
البنيان
الناس تظهر ايضا خوفا من المصير المترتب
على الزلزال ليس فقط فقد الروح او الاصابه
الجسيمه التي من الممكن ان تبقي الشخص
طيله حياته من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه ولا
الالام النفسيه المترتبه على عيش هذا
الظرف العظيم انما ايضا الخلع من المكان
وهذه مساله شديده الحساسيه وبالغه القسوه
ان انسانا يفقد مكانه وذكرياته في لحظه
حين يفقد بيته او جهده من الشارع الذي
يقطن فيه حتى لو اعيد بناءه فهو فقد ايضا
العالم القديم الذي ينتمي اليه ومن ثم كل
هذه الاسباب تؤدي الى الذعر الذعر ايضا
المترتب على فقدان استثمارات من استثمره
في الشقق او في البنايات او في العق ارات
زعر من فقد الاهل والاصحاب والاصدقاء زعر
من فقد المال وبعض المقتنيات النفيسه في
ركامل
خلينا نحاول
اننا نخفف شويه من هذا الذعر ربما بتقديم
بعض النصائح سيد احمد
ما النصائح نحن نقرا بالعديد من التعليقات
النصائح كيف يجب تعامل مع الهزلت الارضيه
ولكن بحسب خبره حظرتك ما الذي يجب ان يفعل
في اللحظات الاولى من الاحساس بهذا
الارضيه
اولا يجب ان يفعل جميع المدنيه هو الحفاظ
على الهدوء التامه
اعلن تماما وانا كنت البارحه اثناء
الزلزال في
طابقا انه صعب جدا ولكن قد يكلف يكلف
حياتنا او يكلف بعض الاشخاص ايضا الى
اصابات بليغه انا بالامس كان احد الاشخاص
بالجواري وانا اقول له ان نقوم بجانب
طاوله ولكن هو اصر على الوقوف على شرقه
المنزل واراد ان
يقفز
هنالك امور صعبه ولكن يجب ولكن سيد احمد
ان اهدى صحيح صحيح صحيح ولكن ما الذي
يعنيه ان اهدا ان اهدا وان افكر لبعض
اللحظات ان اتصرف ان اتحرك
بالنسبه لموضوع الهزات الارتداديه هي عم
تكون عباره عن ثواني
بالامس كانت عباره عن من زمان الى عشره
ثواني فقط لا غير يجب ان نفكر ولو للحظه
في المكان الذي يجب ان نختاره انا عندما
اكون في منطقه علويه يجب ان افكر الى اين
ان اذهب ان اركض مباشره الى خارج البناء
بالسرعه القصوى ان احافظ ايضا على الهدوء
تبقى حضرتك ما الامثل نحن نستمع لك سيد
احمد ان كنت تسمعنا طبعا سيد احمد قد نعود
له بعد لحظات لا اعلم صار خلل تقني من
عنده ساطرح عليك سؤال دكتور عمار ان كانت
لك طبعا متابعه بالموضوع ما الامثل من بين
كل ما تحدثنا عنه
افكر اهدا طيب ولكن فيما بعد ماذا افعل
هو ظرف انساني عصيب يعني كثير من النصائح
موجوده سواء قدمتها مؤسسات مختصه او بعض
اطباء علم النفس اطباء النفسيين او علماء
النفس او بعض اصحاب الخبرات السابقه يعني
هناك نصار كبير جدا من النصائح المتفرقه
الموجوده على الشبكه العنكبوتيه وفي بطون
الكتب لكن هذه اكبر ازمه من الممكن ان
تواجه انسان يعني الازمه تعريفها وقت ضيق
وامر يتعلق بمساله جوهريه ونقص في
المعلومات اعتقد ان تعبير الازمه يتجسد
بالكليه وفي اقصى
بالسين واقصى بالصاد صوره في حاله الزلزال
لان اولا ليس هناك تنبؤ قاطع بالزلازل
ايضا الانسان لا يختار المكان الذي يكون
وقت وقوع الزلزال لا يوجد انذار مثل ما هو
الحال في الحديث
ثواني قليله قد تكلف البعض حياتهم وحياه
اعز ما يملكون ولهذا يطرح سؤال يعني هل
حضرتك مختص في علم الاجتماع تدافع عن فكره
ان يكون هناك متابعه ان يكون هناك حرص على
تحديث المعلومات على التوجه للناس بخطابات
لتمكينها من النصائح مثلا ما الذي يجب
فعله من هذه الناحيه
اولا يجب على كل دوله
تقع في حزام زلازل قائم او محتمل ان يكون
لديها خطه وضمن هذه الخطه ان توعى الناس
سواء في المناهج الدراسيه او عبر الاعلام
او مؤسسات المجتمع المدني لابد من ان يكون
كل فرد في هذه الدوله لديه
خبره ما في التعامل مع الزلازل تمنحه بعض
الاطمئنان ان وقع الامر العصيب ثانيا هذه
الخطه تتيح للدوله ان تدير الازمه باقتدار
ومن ثم تقلل حجم الخسائر الان من ذلك مع
كافر بخصوص هذه الخطه لا تقتل الذي
يقتنيه الابنيه الفاسده هي التي تتسبب في
كثير من الحق بقت لنا بعض ثواني سنختمه
معك سيد احمد منذ قليل تحدثت عن ترتيبات
ان اهدا ان افكر لبعض لحظات وهذا صعب تطلب
مني المستحيل ولكن اركض واخرج او احتمي
بمكان في البيت ما هو الانسب
الاحتماء بالبيت هو انسب فكره للخروج باقل
الخسائر الاحتمال يجب ان يكون بجانب
الطاوله او مكان مقاسي
على كل اعتقد بان نعم
نبقى في متابعه هذا الموضوع سنكتفي بهذا
القدر بما ان توقيت الحلقه
انتهى من القاهره دكتور عمار علي حسن
الاجتماع ومن صار مدى عضو مجلس اداره
الدفاع المدني السوري احمد شكرا لكما
والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]